hi
i hope you are enjoying the itcs
conference and thanks for coming toward
hulk
my name is kevin tien and i'm excited to
share with you a recent work titled
relative luciousness and extra gradient
methods and a direct recipe for
acceleration
this is joint work with michael b cohen
from mit and my advisor aaron siffer
from stanford
in our paper we study algorithms for a
broad family of problems called solving
variational equal inequalities or vis
in monotone operators if i had to
briefly summarize the main takeaways of
our work
they'd be as follows first we showed
that a more fine-grained analysis
of existing algorithms for solving vis
based on bounding a parameter we call
relative religiousness
yields improved rates of convergence in
various interesting applications
notably a number of custom analyses for
solving special cases of bis
which yield rates not predicted by the
standard bi theory and appears somewhat
disappeared at a glance
fall under our framework and thus can be
explained by a single unified technique
the resulting proofs are usually quite
straightforward and amount to a few
applications of koshi shorts
and we hope they demystify these
previous analyses
so one example of such a special vi
algorithm i'll focus on in this talk
is nestera's accelerated gradient
descent this algorithm was introduced in
the 80s and it's a landmark result in
optimization theory
but its prefacement is described by
experts as quite mysterious
in this talk we will see a complete
novel proof of acceleration as an
instance of another existing
optimization algorithm
this is the first such example to our
knowledge
our paper also defines the expected
version of relative deliciousness and
shows that a new
analysis of stochastic bi algorithms
yields improved grades for structured
problems and more fine-grained
randomized accelerated methods
that are found in the literature
finally a third application captured by
our framework is approximation
algorithms for undirected mass flow
in particular we show that the area
convexity framework recently proposed by
sherman for this problem
is recovered by a fine-grained analysis
of standard bi algorithms
our framework also extends to a number
of other interesting settings improving
in some regimes fine
grain rates for minimax optimization and
recovering so-called optimistic analyses
of mirror descent
now before we jump into the details i
wanted to give a brief overview of how
to watch this talk the main theme i try
to capture
what is what i wish someone had told me
about variational inequalities and
acceleration before we started this
project
in fact this project basically fell out
of trying to re-understand these
algorithms from first principles
and this is the spirit i hope to try to
convey in my talk
the first half of the talk will largely
be a primer on extra great
methods for solving vs so don't worry if
these words don't mean anything to you
right now
i'll try to make the gold to the
algorithm as intuitive as possible
and seeing the analysis will make it
easier to appreciate the main definition
of this paper
which is relatively legitness for the
experts watching this talk
feel free to jump ahead if you don't
need the primer
after stating the condition we used to
analyze the convergence rate of extra
gradient methods
we'll immediately see the payoff so as
promised i'll give a full con
i'll give a complete proof of
acceleration accepting one or two
technical details
and the proof will fall out of our
framework quite straightforwardly and a
couple of
simple calculations and finally the last
part of the talk will be about some
further applications
and generalizations of our method to
local and randomized settings
i'll conclude with some thoughts on
future directions to take our framework
to start i'll begin by describing the
problem family we study
a vi problem is parameterized by a
monotone operator g
from a set to its stool which satisfies
the displayed
condition informally it forces the
results of the operator on two points
to be aligned with the direction between
these two points
we'll mostly only consider two examples
of monotone operators in this talk
the first is just the gradient of a
convex function and we'll prove this as
monotony just a second
the second is what we call the gradient
operator of a convex concave function on
two blocks
and notice that the second block of g is
negated so when talking about a convex
concave function we'll always call the
convex block x
and the concave block y to convince
yourself that example one is really a
monotone operator
the proof just sums convexity from x to
y and convexity from y to x
and the proof that example 2 is monotone
is very very similar
we now have now we now define
variational inequalities
in short solving a vi in a monotone
operator g just ask us to find a point x
star
such that the inner product between g of
x star and x star minus
x for any x in the domain is
non-positive
for those familiar with mere descent
algorithms this condition has a natural
interpretation as a one-step regret
guarantee
in the case of example one this amounts
to just minimizing the conics function
the fact that this solves the associated
vi in the gradient is commonly referred
to as
first order optimality in the case of
example two
the solution of the bi is the saddle
point or nash equilibrium
of the convex concave function and the
proof that solving the vi for a convex
concave game
yields a saddle point follows from the
observation that the inner product of
g and the difference between the point
um
that g that's the argument for g and any
other point x
y upper bound is the difference between
f of x star y
and f of x y star and if you haven't
seen this before
this proof just follows from an
application of convexity and concavity
and it has a natural interpretation as
the change in utility from two players x
star y star
deviating in their responses to new
points x and y
now maximizing this quantity over all
choices x and y is commonly referred to
as a duality gap
and when the duality gap is non-positive
we have found an equilibrium
and we'll basically only be discussing
one family of algorithms for solving
fias in this talk
and we will collectively refer to them
as ex-gradient methods
they were first analyzed in the context
of lipschitz operators by nemourovsky
and nestorov 15 years ago
we'll be focusing on nemeropsi's version
in this talk but we also discussed
of version in the paper these methods
apply to a vi
in an operator g and are driven by
regularizer r
and the pair g comma r defines the
subsidy algorithm
typically when analyzing extra gradient
methods the regularizer r
is assumed to be strongly convex which
means it has some positive curvature and
a specified norm
this is a strengthening of the standard
convexity definition which allows for
zero curvature
a typical a typical example is when r is
just a squared euclidean distance
we'll later talk about how to relax this
assumption of strong convexity of r
now we'll talk about rates for extra
gradient methods with a strongly convex
regularizer
in 2004 namorovsky showed that when the
operator g
is lipschitz with parameter lambda the
method converges to a solution at a rate
of lambda over t and t
iterations under the assumption that the
operator g is not only monotone but also
m strongly monotone
with respect to the regularizer r which
is the definition here
the method converges at the displayed
rate so roughly you can think that
the distance to the optimizer decreases
by a constant factor
every lambda over m iterations if this
is your first time seeing these kinds of
rates i encourage you to pause the video
now to familiarize yourself with them
they'll serve as benchmarks for the rest
of the talk
so we summarize the classical rates of
extra credit methods on the left of this
slide for reference which is what we
just discussed
basically assuming that the
regularization is strongly have x and
the operator is lipschitz
the method is converging at a lambda
over t rate
and under the further assumption that
the operator is strongly monotone the
rate is exponential in this parameter
lambda over m
and you can think of this parameter as a
condition number for monotone operators
under these minimal assumptions these
rates were both shown to be tight
even in the case when the norm
everything is measured in is euclidean
however for a number of structured
examples of variational inequalities
it's known that we can improve upon the
rates predicted by the standard theory
perhaps the most famous example of a
known improvement is the case of solving
a vi
and a gradient of the convex function so
as a reminder this is equivalent to just
minimizing
the function nesteroff's accelerated
gradient descent method
roughly obtains a quadratic improvement
on the predictions of standard extra
gradient analyses
for just the special case
another more recent example of a
structure case guilty improvements which
we think
is of particular interest to a tcs
audience instead of l infinity
regression
and this setup has applications to max
flow which we'll operate on later
obtaining one over t rates of
conversions for this problem using
standard techniques
without worse dependence on dimensions
was a notorious obstacle until a
breakthrough work of sherman in 2017.
this obstacle was because known lower
bounds showed that any strongly convex
function in this norm
has diameter growing linearly with the
problem dimension
and was overcome by a new analysis
called area convexity
finally a number of other mysteries
surround exaggerated methods
for example it remains unclear what
types of structured bis allow for 1 over
2 rates of convergence
by stochastic methods which would match
the rate of their
deterministic counterparts in terms of
dependence on t
and in another line of research a
perspective known as optimism was
proposed to analyze these algorithms
which
we'll talk about briefly later
so the main conceptual contribution of
our paper is a new condition
characterizing the convergence rate of
extra gradient methods
beyond the standard setup of ellipses g
and astronomy convex are and our our new
characterization boils down to a simple
to verify relationship between the pair
g and r and make sure that this new
framework captures the tailored analyses
of the set
of several of the structured instances
that we mentioned
so we'll now give a general introduction
to extracting algorithms
and we'll start by describing an
idealized version of these methods which
is known as the proximal point method
so for the next few slides we're going
to focus on the special case of
minimizing a convex function f
consider defining a sequence of iterates
by the displayed equation
the function v um v of
r uh v superscript r sub x k
is known as the bregman divergence from
a point x k
and you can think of it as a a possibly
non-euclidean notion of
distance and intuitively the objective
to finding the next degree is a truss
region method
it tries to minimize the function f
which is the overall goal without
straying too far from the previous
iterate
by tuning the parameter lambda we
interpolate between these two goals
we now formally define the bregman
divergence it's simply the difference
between r of x
and a linear approximation of it from a
point x k
and when r is convex the divergence is
always non-negative
and when it's further strongly convex
the divergence grows at least
quadratically with the distance
if this is your first time seeing this
it's useful to keep the example when r
is just the
euclidean quadratic regularizer in mind
and in this case the divergence is
the you put it as squared
we'll leave the the definition of
divergence here for
convenience and by directly writing down
the first order optimality conditions of
the
minimization problem in defining x
cables one
we arrive at the displayed equation
by well-known manipulation the
right-hand inner products can be written
as a relationship between three bregman
divergences
and we'll simply drop the third
divergence because it's always
non-negative
this leads us to the main technical
claim for the practical point method
which we summarize here and by directly
applying this claim in a few different
ways
this leads to different convergence
guarantees under a few different
settings
by directly summing this guarantee over
two iterations and taking an average
we see by convexity that the
approximation error of the average
iterate goes down at roughly a lambda
over t rate
and the key observation here is that the
right hand side telescopes
so we simply pay the initial divergence
averaged over all the iterations
the right-hand side being the difference
of pregnant differences
if you further assume that the gradient
is one strongly monotone with respect to
the regularizer
which basically means the function f
itself is strong convex
it's not hard to see that combining this
with the first order optionality
condition
above means that the divergence to the
minimizer
x star is shrinking by roughly a one
over lambda factor every iteration
so this means that up to a logarithmic
term we can find a highly accurate
optimizer of the function in lambda
iterations
and you might notice that so far i
haven't uh said anything about what the
parameter lambda actually is
and you can think of this lambda as a
step size uh the reason i haven't said
anything is because the proximal point
method is just an idealized algorithm
so typically it's not easy to actually
confuse compute in closed form
the iterates that it defines um but
intuitively the smaller
that lambda is the faster the
convergence rate of the method
but the more uh the more expensive the
problems defining the iterates
might be because they look more and more
like our original problem which is
minimizing f
so summarize the key takeaways of the
previous slides here
in short the proximal point method is
just an idealized method for minimizing
a function f
which solves a sequence of sub-problems
each of which minimizes f
plus a regularizer and the main
technical lemma about the iterates is
also written here which we just proved
a classical first order method known as
mere descent basically modifies the
problems defining these iterates
slightly
so instead of minimizing the regularized
function mirror sent repeatedly
minimizes regularized linearizations of
the function
and when the regularizer r is simple we
can actually compute these linearized
iterates in exposed form
compared to the optimality guarantees of
proximal point the optimality
conditions of mere descent are very
similar and in fact the only difference
here is that the left-hand side has a
gradient of xk the previous iterate
rather than x cables one this is because
we we minimize the linearization instead
of the function itself
however in order to guarantee uh convert
this guarantee into function error
we'd really like the gradient of the
next iterate x k plus one
so to remedy this we just add the
difference between the gradient inner
products to both sides
so this extra um term that pops up can
basically be thought of as a
discretization error
and ultimately controlling this error
will lead to a trade-off on the
subsidized landmark that we take
if we make land the larger again we'll
make we'll get a slower convergence rate
but the discretization error that we
showed here um will also become smaller
which is good
so finally we have all the intuition we
need to define executive methods
here's the basic idea um we really want
the optimality conditions for the next
x k was 1 to have its own gradient in
the picture so this corresponds to the
approximate point method
so informally you can think of this next
iterate x k plus 1
as the solution to a fixed point
iteration because its own gradient shows
up in the aquatic guarantee
and extra gradient methods basically
just take mere descent to the next level
by
by iterating a few uh a few steps in
order to
um hope to simulate this fixed point
iteration
here's what the extra great method with
exactly two iterations looks like
and it's the algorithm that we'll focus
on for the rest of the talk
so this extra gradient method with
exactly two steps is called the mirror
prox method in the literature
and was analyzed by namorowski in 2004.
so his main observation was that when
the operator g is loop sheets
and the regularizer are a strong convex
you only need two iterations of this
extra gradient method
to recover the one over two rate of
convergence for the ideal proximal point
method
the proof strategy is quite
straightforward so similar to the mirror
descent if you do an
analysis of mere procs a discretization
error term pops out of the first order
optimality conditions
and the key takeaway um of uh
namrovsky's work
is that the discretization error
actually doesn't hurt us
as long as we take a large enough value
of the parameter lambda
so in particular when the operator is l
lipschitz nemerovsky showed that the
discretization error is non-positive
for all lambda at least l so all large
enough uh lambda
and the condition we pros in our work
for analyzing activated methods just
directly falls out of this analysis so
we just call this
this total requirement that the
discretization error be non-positive
a relative loop systems condition so we
named this following a similar condition
called relative smoothness which
appeared in the convict's optimization
literature so just minimizing a complex
function
and note that our condition can be
precisely described as the relationship
between
the operator g and a regularizer r
localized to the points in any
particular iteration
so when g and r satisfy this
relationship with some parameter lambda
we say that g is lambda relative
ellipses with respect to r
intuitively the left-hand side of this
guarantee can be thought of as
how much the operator g dilutes an inner
product defined by three points
and the right-hand side just asks what
multiple of the divergence is between
these points
do we need to upper bound these inner
products
i should mention that this condition is
quite natural and its statement actually
appeared in independent work earlier
this year by stan dekina
however i want to emphasize that we view
the observation that applying this
condition to a number of
uh important applications yields
improved convergence rates as
our key novel contribution of this work
so we'll first show that a
straightforward adaptation of
nemorovsky's
analysis shows that when operator g is
lambda relatively lipschitz
in r um we obtain a lambda over t rated
convergence
so this just falls uh straight out of
the mirrorpox proof we should uh we
we saw earlier
and uh when g further satisfies both
relative low distances
and strong monotonicity um the rate of
convergence improves exponentially to
linear
in the ratio lambda over m so note that
both of these rates match the earlier
um standard bi setup uh race that we
showed earlier
um we wanted to emphasize that our new
condition is a looser requirement than
the traditional analysis
which requires gdp lipschitz and are to
be strongly convex
and the few application applications of
basic inequalities show that an operator
regularizer pair
satisfying uh the standard more
stringent requirements also satisfies
relative license
and we'll demonstrate this now so by
applying young's inequality
we can bound the inner product on the
left-hand side of the
rl definition as so and by using that g
as lipschitz
and the bragging divergences of the
strongly convex function are themselves
strong convex
we get the rl condition um
however we emphasize that in several
important cases even when
uh the operator is not rubbishes and the
regularizer is not strong convex
the pair still satisfy their definition
and gets a better convergence rate for
that reason
so we can now discuss our main
application the punch line
which is recovering accelerated rates
for convex optimization
and we'll focus on the following setup
let f be a convex function we are trying
to minimize
and assume that its gradient is l
lipschitz and the function itself is mu
shelling convex
i will assume that the relevant norm is
euclidean for now but in the paper we
deal with general numbers
and it's well known that the setup is
equivalent to upper and lower bounds on
the eigenvalues of the second derivative
matrix of f
um a naive way of solving the associated
variant of
vi or in simply terms just minimizing f
is just letting g be the gradient of f
then by using the framework of the
previous slide since gsl lipschitz and
muse following a monotone
when using the squared you couldn't norm
as the regularizer
the extra green algorithm halves the
error in roughly l over mu iterations
however even in the 80s nest drop knew
that we could obtain a faster
convergence rate
by accelerated gradient descent
depending instead on the square root of
l over mu
and the the key question here is can we
show this is not actually a limitation
of extra gradient methods
it turns out the key insight is to
slightly rewrite the problem into an
equivalent
mini-max optimization problem this
minimax optimization
formulation was called the ventral gain
by wong and abernathy in 2018.
let h be the result of subtracting mu
over 2 times the square including norm
from f
and notice by the strong convex
assumption the function h itself is
still convex
differential gain we defined is in terms
of the differential dual of the function
h this function which we call h star is
sometimes
also called the convex conjugate and the
definition of h star
which is also displayed here for
convenience is just basically copy
pasted into the minimax formulation
we're essentially only going to use two
facts about the complex conjugate
the first is that h star is one over l
strongly convex which is well known to
follow from the fact that h is l smooth
the second is that the maximizing
argument in the definition of h star
can be written as a gradient of h
it's not hard to see that the saddle
point of the ventral game has in its
first block the minimizer of the
original function f
uh to solve the factual game problem we
um our choice of algorithm is just mere
procs
and to define the algorithm we also need
to specify an operator g and regulator
power
the operator g is just going to be the
gradient operator of the potential game
which is convex concave
and we will use a separable regularizer
to draw the algorithm which is the sum
of mu over 2 times squared euclidean
norm on x block
and h star differential dual on the y
block
so following our framework to obtain a
rate of the algorithm we just need to
prove two bounds
the first is just that the operator g is
exactly one strongly monotone
with respect to the regularized
redefined this follows since the
operator is almost exactly the same
gradient of r
plus the result of a bilinear coupling
term in the definition of g
this coupling term ends up exactly
canceling out
so all that's left is just about the rl
parameter between the pair g and r
so just as a reminder we can write the
definition of rl um here
and it involves three points which we
call z w and u
note that each of these points actually
has two blocks which is superscript is x
and y sorry for a lot of notation but
hopefully it's clear what i mean
and we went ahead and expanded out the
left-hand side of the definition it
involves
four inner products
we can think of the first two inner
products as non-cross terms since the
only involved inner products between x
variables and x variables are y and y
it turns out that these two inner
products are straightforward to upper
bound in terms of fragment divergences
essentially well-known inequalities
which is followed from convexity
show that the nine cross terms
contribute one multiple of the right
hand side to the rl bound
so so far we're at lambda equals one
the bottom line for the rate follows
from the rl for the cross terms and
these are the terms involving an inner
product between y variables and x
variables
so to bound these we start by applying
kochi shorts and then
by using young's inequality we obtain
the following bounds of the products
however each of the sums in the
parentheses can now be bounded by a
bregman divergence in the regularizer
bar
so to see this we use that the x bound
um the x block of the regularizer is mu
strong chemix
and the y block is one over astronomy
convex so overall these terms contribute
a square root l over mu multiple the
right hand side
to the rl bound note that in order to
obtain these bound
um on the non-cross terms we had to
crucially use interactions between the
primal and the dual blocks
so one interpretation of this is that
acceleration is fundamentally a primal
dual phenomenon
and finally putting together both bounds
shows that g is one plus square root l
over mu
relative ellipses with respect to r
there is a technical detail that we
haven't described how to solve the sub
problems defining theater is
uh it's actually quite straightforward
to implement these steps for the x block
but for the y block
we can use the fact that that maximizing
arguments for the ventral sub problem
are actually gradients and this lets us
maintain the y variables implicitly
throughout the algorithm
where we explicitly compute the points
that they're grading up and maintain
those
the idea of regularizing the dual
function with itself and the observation
that the iterations are actually
implementable
are very crucial to our rate and we
think this is a nice trick and hope it
has further applications
and putting together the strong
monotonic bound to the previous slide
the rl bound to this slide
and this implicit maintenance trick
gives a complete accelerated algorithm
we'll give a short description of a few
other interesting applications of rl
and it's extensions that we've had we
find in our paper
the first uses what we call local
relativelyness
which is a fancy way of saying the
analysis of extra green methods
um only actually cares about rl applied
to the iterates of the algorithm
rather than totally arbitrary points
uh we apply this tool to an application
in computing approximate undirected
maximum flows
it was absurd it was observed by
breakthrough works of sherman kellner
alan peng
that the problem of approximate max flow
can be reduced to a small number of
combinatorially preconditioned l
infinity regression problems
the resulting regression matrix has a
poly logarithmic
l infinity operator norm
um as we briefly alluded to earlier one
difficulty in applying the standard
extra gradient analysis to this
regression problem
is the fact that um is it is that the
standard analysis requires a strongly
convex regularizer
and it turns out that there is no
strongly convex regulator in the l
infinity norm of a box
um over a box whose
size scales sublinearly in the problem
dimension so this
leads to worse rates sherman actually
showed how to overcome this difficulty
in a breakthrough work in 2017 by
considering a primal dual form of
elementary regression
and he saw the associated bi by
designing a new excavating algorithm and
analyzed it through a weakening of
strong complexity which he called area
convexity
in our work we show that the original
extravagant algorithms in the morosky
and nestorov
applied to this vi problem when driven
by sherman's regularizer
also obtained the same rates of the
constants the proof follows directly
from a rl bound
and crucially in the proof we use the
fact that the iterates on one of the
blocks is stable
up to constant factors so we can obtain
a stronger local bound
a second property of the rl framework is
that it extends fairly straightforwardly
to randomization to provi
uh to provide some context there's a
general gap in our understanding of
stochastic variants of extra gradient
methods
in particular under a boundary variance
assumption on the stochastic operators
used
the resulting convergence rate of
extroverted method scales is t to the
minus one-half
which is worse than their deterministic
counterparts
but on the other hand for specific cases
of vis such as the casting convex
optimization
it's actually known how to design
reduced variance randomized operators
which
obtain convergence rates going like one
over t and the natural question is can
these variation operators be extended
more generally to extra gradient methods
one difficulty behind using uh
randomness and extra gradient methods is
that the randomness of the first
gradient step
already causes a variation in the second
step so even notions like unbiasedness
become a bit hard to define since the
intermediate iterates themselves are
also random
we give a simple set of conditions which
randomize extra great methods
can converge uh which allowed them to
converge at a one over t rate
which makes progress towards
understanding this mystery this
formalizes and generalizes ideas from
earlier work of aaron and me on
coordinate methods for max flow
and basically the point is if a point of
if a notion of unbiasedness
holds with respect to an average
intermediate point um x bar
and an expected version of relative
distance hold
uh we recover similar to castigrace as
the deterministic counterparts but with
possibly
much cheaper iterations because our
randomized algorithms makes the gradient
operators of intermediate iterates
share randomness we describe our method
as a local variance reduction method
we showed that by applying this
framework to the central game we can
recover
rates of randomized accelerated
coordinate descent through
extra gradient methods and finally we
described um
briefly a few other results contained in
the paper and avenues for further
exploration
so first there's been a considerable
recent interest in characterizing the
fine-grained complexity of mini max
optimization and by fine grained
we mean the dependence of the method on
each of these block-wise smoothness
bounds
on the hessian of a convex concave
function f in terms of the operator
norms
so several recent exciting works have
made significant progress in obtaining
improved fine-grained dependencies on
these problem parameters
however a gap still remains between
these upper bounds and the lower bound
in an artwork we give a simple
application of rl which obtains an
alternative rate for a range of smooth
parameters
improving known upper bounds in some
cases
there are other ways to obtain this rate
but our framework makes the calculation
very straightforward
and it would be really interesting to
explore if the techniques of our paper
can close the gap
we're also interested in applications of
a of a perspective on extra graded
methods known as optimism
proposed by rocklin and sriran
um this perspective has gained interest
in the mission learning community and
several works have studied its
application
towards training uh general generator of
adversarial networks
and we showed that the original optimism
analysis is captured by the rl toolkit
and findings exploring further
applications of optimism within our
framework can be quite interesting
and finally we're also interested in
developing a more general theory of
variance reduction for randomized extra
gradient methods
and as a concrete application it'd be
really interesting to recover
accelerated variants of
sgd for convex optimization within our
analysis framework
um thank you again for listening to our
presentation and if you are interested
in some of the finer detail that were
glossed over in the talk
i encourage you to check out our paper
which is linked here